um
and i'd like to mention that um
four of our films were actually
profitable so it might be against your
principles
um one was unprofitable
it's the one with a thousand extras and
a disco
but warner brothers paid for that so we
don't have to worry about it
and um so if we do decide to do
film investing together i'd like to
mention how we do it
to show that our our interests are
aligned
i put in a certain investment like 10
000
into the investment vehicle and then you
put in your 10 000 in the investment
vehicle
and do any of you know the con where the
guy does the rolled up
uh dollars under the arm in the old in
the 70s that was done a lot it's not
that
it's actually an honest thing and i
thought maybe the first project we could
do together
would be president arne's um churchill's
trials
churchill's trial
because churchill movies are general
they're popular i've always wanted to do
one i can never get that job they get
english people to do it
and um there's sort of three sections of
the book so it could be a series we do
the first one
the war which is commercial and um
if the war works then we do the other
two
so that's how it works in the film
business you have to do sort of a genre
or a series or something like that
anyway um i have to say
i think there's a big problem with this
conference uh
there's far too much emphasis on jane
austen
it gets repetitive
the private theatricals at mansfield
park
have been worked to death um so
tonight i'd prefer to talk about james
bond
the james bond novels have also been
made into films
and so first i'd like to do a kind of
survey
who here has not seen a jane james bond
film
you've not seen one never wow
who has seen the old james bond films
with sean connery and roger moore
great good good good who's read a james
bond novel
okay okay so now now we've done that
um so how did uh
bond become a craze ian fleming's bit of
history
in fleming's first novel casino royale
was published in 1953
and was moderately successful in britain
but in the u.s
where three publishers had wisely turned
it down it ended up flopping
the next year 1954
the cbs network did a one-hour tv
version but they put it into
an anthology series in 1955
film rights to casino royale were sold
but nothing came of that that sale
dr no the six bond novel was published
in 1958
and it's a really good book i recommend
it
paul johnson who became famous later
as a conservative popular historian was
then a man of the left writing in the
new statesman in london
and he excoriated dr no for its sex
snobbery and sadism
one would think that would have piqued
hollywood's interest
but the novel went unsold it was
only the seventh bond novel goldfinger
that in 1961 led canadian producer harry
saltzman
and american cubby broccoli both based
in europe
to license the james bond character for
films several hollywood studios turned
the project down as
two british or two blatantly sexual
in those days hollywood didn't want to
do blatantly sexual
films just the obvious ones
uh but blatant no um
eventually eventually the independent
minus
studio united artists united artists is
a great studio is started by dw griffith
and mary pickford and douglas fairbanks
back in the old days to make their own
films
and it's maintained a tradition until
recent decades
of really being the friendly studio for
independent projects and interesting
projects
so they agreed to to fund dr no as a
modestly budget film
they really had a modest budget four
film directors
turned the film down perhaps because of
the modest budget
anglo irish writer director terence
young signed on
and um he sought to make the film
funny as he considered that quote a lot
of
things in this film the sex and violence
and so on
if played straight would a be
objectionable
b would never go past the sensors but
the
the moment you make it tongue-in-cheek
it seems to disarm
um corners were cut ingeniously to keep
the film within its tight budget
dr knows fabulous aquarium fabulous
aquarium
was actually magnified stock footage of
goldfish
and they actually couldn't afford stock
footage of
scarier fish than goldfish the scarier
footage costs more
but the film was a big success and the
rest is history
except not really the films maintain
their glamorous humorous charm through
the sean connery and roger moore films
but in the decades since then have
become increasingly grim
action films just like other grim action
films
but the initial critical reaction to dr
no was not unmixed
which means it was mixed time
time called bond a blithering bounder
where does time get off to snob james
bond i know
a blithering bounder and a great big
hairy marshmallow
i mean you see sean connery as james
bond you think greg
big hairy marshmallow maybe marshmallow
meant something different then
okay oh he he almost always manages to
seem slightly silly
well anyway the new republic said it
never decides whether
is suspense or suspense spoof
the vatican condemned the film
as a dangerous mixture of violence
vulgarity
sadism and sex the vatican i think was
premature
because i don't think dr no well i guess
it was
um but they'd definitely be correct
about the current films vatican
is on on target um
the kremlin said that bond was the
personification of capitalist evil
so i'm surprised everyone here has not
not seen those films
both these controversies only helped
increase public awareness of the film
and greater cinema attendance thanks
wikipedia
that's from wikipedia so what is this to
do with jane
jane austin well from
the film industry point of view jane
austen novels are like
bond novels material and normally no one
is interested in material
until someone else takes a chance with
it
and it turns out well then some good
works are created but after a while it
becomes a genre and once something
becomes a genre
next becomes a glut it begins to verge
on and more than verge on parity and
travesty
i worry that we're going to make the
world fairly sick of jane austen
which would be a great shame because she
has enormous value for us beyond being a
purveyor
of plot lines for romantic period yarns
and um where am i
oh the next paragraph
some seem to have the impression that it
was ever thus that jane austen
adaptations
have come out in a continuous stream
since time immemorial
not at all how did jane austen finally
become film material sense and
sensibility
her first published book was came out in
1811
the mgm pride and prejudice did not come
out which i think was screened on
sunday did not come out until 1940 it
was not badly received the new york
times reviewed it favorably
but it lost money there would not be
another
major film of jane austen's works
for 55 years you lose
money you don't make films jane austen
was
in the film dog house
1995 was the year of the jane austen big
bang
four projects coming out all successful
in their own terms
when it rains it pours there is sense
and sensibility
i consider the best film adaptation the
column firth television pride and
prejudice version
the best pride and prejudice version
probably there is the film the british
tv
film of persuasion which many people
like it's kind of a doubty version
of a beautiful novel but considered
successful
and in its own terms clueless can be
mentioned a lot of us hate it but no
we don't hate it i just didn't like it
at the time the kind of cool take was oh
clueless is the best jane austen
adaptation
and that turned us against it um the
next year
brought the gwyneth paltrow emma the
cape
beckinsale miniseries emma and the first
the bridget jones novel so heavens
um the floodgates were open jane austen
was material
a go-to source for hacks everywhere and
some non-hacks
the dirty secret of jane austen world
generally austin enthusiasts divide into
two groups this is a dirty secret
those who come to austin from books and
those who mostly approach her from the
film and television adaptations
this week you've heard a lot from those
who approach austin from her novels
and they're very critical of a lot of
the films
in the novels moral character insights
and subtle comedy loom large
and a lot of those things are lost in
films austin film
television fans are more oriented to
romance and darcy's and wet shirts
i'm prejudice but thank
uh but but thanks to film and tv
austin fans who works to become a genre
perhaps georgette
higher hair hair higher georgia higher
barbara cartland
and bridgeton are the next are the next
tendencies
um jane austen in her writing is mostly
anti-romantic
she will give her public the final
outcome they require
but it's quite reserved judgmental
thorny path to get there
she was even more caustic in her private
letters and her
private perceptions so there are
different ways of looking at
and judging film adaptations this week
you've heard a lot of judging the
specific philadel
fidelity of the films to the novels
there's another school of thought
that a film has no obligation to be
faithful to sort of
source material the only question is is
the film a good film in itself how
however unfaithful it might be there are
a couple of theories about adopt
adapting books into film though perhaps
not directly relevant to austin films
um alexander payne is an indie director
who
did a very good film um based on the
novel the descendants
about the dramas in the life of the
dynastic hollywood
hawaiian family has anyone seen the
descendants
yeah it's really good he went to usc
film school you know what usc stands for
sarah know that
university of spoiled children um
very true of the film school especially
um
and i think in the cheating scandal that
was also
confirmed the college shooting scandal
did people cheat to get into hillsdale
yeah i guess so okay
okay usa film school in alexander
payne's day
there's a famous class in book to film
adaptation in which the professor would
ask the students
what the film owes the original book and
they had to shout back
nothing the film owns nothing to the
book
payne's view is that you owe nothing to
the novel but you remain faithful to the
spirit
well it's fine for him to say um in in
austin's case though i think most of the
concerns about faithfulness
which could be considered nitpicking are
justified
certain transformations are not um just
unfaithful to austin's perspective and
insights they introduced them
one turned a classic austin tale into
charlotte bronte romance
why not go to charlotte bronte directly
the adaptation of her great
moral novel mansfield park was traded
with all sorts of contemporary political
and sexual concerns
why why bother why not learn from the
past
when we have the chance to learn from
the past rather than lecturing the past
which can't hear us um certain flawed
books
can can improve with well-chosen
infidelity
ian forster's greatly admired novel
howards and
i i didn't admire
i have to say i i found it manipulative
and tendentious
one family absolutely charming sensitive
and wonderful the other terribly
terribly bad
and probably republican except they're
in england um
for the film uh the director james ivory
uh screenwriter ruth barajas
and and the cast of anthony hopkins emma
emma thompson's getting a lot of credit
this week
emma thompson vanessa redgrave
transformed howard's end into something
really wonderful
subtle and beautiful and much fairer to
the different people
although the the bad people were still
pretty bad
um when it comes to hollywood search for
material what's
in and what's out james bond and jane
austen are in
charles dickens and anthony trollope are
out
many of the dynamics of social tension
and moral observation
people credit for austin's popularity
would also apply well to trollop
he has also has a reformist perspective
some people
approach austin for lacking and there
are 47
of the trollop novels not just six so
maybe we can hope and look forward to
that
i recall a meeting a decade or more ago
with a very nice producer
someone had sent her a project about
werewolves
she was excoriating everyone knows it's
vampires people want to see
young people today only want vampires
how could these people be so clueless as
to propose a werewolf project
little did she suspect that zombies of
all things were just around the corner
werewolves still haven't happened i
don't think
but there's always hope and and i think
there's a popular series that is a
wolverine
character and so maybe that's getting
close okay
adapting austin so jane austen like
james bond is material
i experienced this myself trying to
write my first film metropolitan
i needed things for people to say to
each other to argue about defining their
characters and relationships
i the idea that the the heroine called
audrey because she was also inspired by
audrey hepburn
was a kind of fanny price
first jane austen collaboration was
slight and nearly
accidental beginning as do many things
with the misunderstanding
i was praising austin's mansfield park
to a literally minded friend
when he informed me that the literary
critic lionel trilling whom we both
admired
had destroyed mansfield park
particularly its first
virtuous heroine fanny price trilling
had written
nobody i believe has ever found it
possible to like the heroine of
mansfield park
fanny price is overtly virtuous and
consciously virtuous
our modern literary feeling is very
strong
against people who when they mean to be
virtuous
believe they know how to reach their
goal and to reach it
we think that virtue is not interesting
don't come to hillsdale
even that even that is not really virtue
unless it manifests itself as a product
of grace operating through
a strong inclination to sin
wow our favorite saint is likely to be
augustine
at this point we'll pause for
film clips so i hope it works
[Music]
and by jane austen persuasion and
mansfield park
mansfield park you've got to be kidding
no
but it's a notoriously bad book even
lionel trilling one of her greatest
admirers thought that
well if lionel trilling thought that
he's an idiot
the whole story revolves around what the
immorality of a group of young people
putting on a play
in the context of a novel it makes
perfect sense
but the context of the novel and nearly
everything jane austen wrote is
ridiculous from today's perspective
has it ever occurred to you that today
looked at from jane austen's perspective
would look even worse
no let's do the next lights
i read that lionel trilling essay you
mentioned you really like drilling
yes i think he's very strange
he says that nobody could like the
heroine of mansfield park
i like her then he goes on and on about
how we modern people of today with our
modern attitudes bitterly resent
mansfield park because
its heroine is virtuous what's wrong
with the novel having a virtuous heroine
his point is that the novel's premise
there's something immoral in a group of
young people putting on a play
is simply absurd you found fanny price
unlikable
she sounds pretty unbearable but i
haven't read the book what
you don't have to read a book to have an
opinion on it i haven't read the bible
either
what jane austen novels have you read
none i don't read novels
i prefer good literary criticism that
way you get both the novelist's idea as
well as the critics thinking
with fiction i can never forget that
none of it ever really happened but it's
all just made up by the author
[Applause]
thank you so jane austen threw me a
lifeline
uh uh for for for for this movie uh
uh trilling um in his essay
is incredulous um at one of the novel's
key controversies
and you've been over this so many times
i hate to bring it up when fanny prices
bertram cousins and their guests propose
to put on a play at home and she objects
citing the absent uncle and her ex and
uncle and ben factor's opposition to
them
i mean i think a lot of the descriptions
of fannie's objections to the
theatricals
um are off in the sense that she's not
against theatrical she's not her
justification theatricals it's the
pacifi
specific situation with her her
uncle who's laid down the law against
this happening
um very firmly and he's taken her in
she came from such a horrible background
in portsmouth and
he generously has treated her as a
daughter
and he's gone and her elder cousin
the miss bertrand um has a very fragile
engagement
um that's sort of in jeopardy and the
idea
of the danger of this play in her
fragile situation so i think people sort
of
are unfair to jane austen and fanny
price and how this is all happening
it was sort of a lifeline for me in
getting this material it's very hard
sort of to come up with plot and
situations that reveal characters and
advance the story
and so i started thinking what could be
like this sort of indefensible position
that someone takes where it
isolates them from everyone else like
someone who does not want to do
something
everyone else wants to do it and their
objections seem
stupid and silly and they're idiots and
why are you why do you want to do this
and this happens a lot and
i remembered a case shortly after
college
where there was one of those truth or
dare games
and i didn't like the idea very much i
didn't object to it
and it was really terrible i mean some
people ask questions they shouldn't have
asked
and the people felt obliged to answer
when they shouldn't have answered and it
was really embarrassing and bad
bad bad and so i thought maybe
someone could sort of a more frivolous
type could
put you know propose a truth or dare uh
session
and audrey objects
and she's isolated and and then
something comes out in
in that that's that's that's sad and and
bad and advances the plot
so anyway it really helped me out i mean
it's small in the whole movie but the
jane austen element
was helpful um
also as aside one thing i've been
thrilled here
i normally am blocked from jstor do you
know what jstor is
all the normally i have to you know do
some login and i can look at it but i
can't download i'm such a cheapskate
um and there's just so many things i
want to research and i come to jstor and
say okay now i can read it okay
quickly i can't download it and then
magically i was here in my room
and i'd code things and i could download
it said download
download okay download so
so tomorrow morning i'm going to be
downloading every article i've ever want
to read
thank you hillsdale
so anyway metropolitan even got to be
considered
a stealth adaptation of mansfield park
by some people so it got jane austen
talked about a little bit
um oh and about these um essays
the lionel trilling essay is really
great it's a really um
fascinating essay uh he published it in
the partisan review in 1954
and collected it in his book the
opposing self and
it's also just available free on the
internet i guess it's been pirated
um and um then
there is a wonderful essay replying to
it
from a retired smith college professor
who recently died at 100 years old so we
don't have to be aside
his name is paul pickerel and he wrote
this essay lionel trilling and mansfield
park
it's on jstor and it's really
interesting
he destroys drilling but nicely
so my second jane austen adaptation
learning experience came
um i was really lucky with metropolitan
um i was completely accessible
and happy to meet with anyone and do any
project
in fact there's sort of a set thing with
indie filmmakers oh my god is it getting
that late
i better hurry up um so
that you make a first film then studios
come to call and you get to make james
bond films or
interesting films you have to make your
indie films but i want to make a second
indie film which is real mistake because
then they think oh you're only going to
do these little films
they can draw a line between the two
anyway i was in the editing room for the
second film barcelona
and i already had the idea for the third
film the last days of disco
and um a producer came i was working
with this company castle rock which rob
reiner
um started and it's a great company and
they back three of my films so i'm
really grateful to them
and this wonderful producer lindsey
duran had worked there
and she wanted to adapt sense and
sensibility and she went first to rob
runner because she thought there
should be a character comedy guy who
does this character comedy guy rob
runner passed on it
she came to me i had this idea that i
should
write original stories and then film
them and i was in between these two
projects and
um and but i read the script and it was
emma thompson's early draft emma
thompson script
and it started just with the dialogue
scene so she took the novel
got to the part where their dialogue and
and dramatized them
and it seemed very drawing room and and
sort of not dramatic and not passionate
so i read the novel
and i realized there's a very brief
narration at the beginning without
dialogue
and that it gives a whole predicament of
these sisters
who are the second family
of um i mean if you've seen the film so
you all know the story
and how the sister-in-law talks
um their elder brother away from the
promise
he gave their father to take care of
them so so they're left
essentially destitute in a horrible
predicament
and um uh lizard said yeah that started
us thinking about that and
wonderful director came on to do that
angrily with a writing collaborator
james sheamus they worked with emma
thompson i think
that film turned out so well i think
because you had these really brilliant
filmmakers
and then someone who really loved austin
was really close to it and knew this for
amelia emma thompson
and that collaboration was so wonderful
and it really taught me to learn
that you can't really judge a script by
an early draft you
it's very hard to imagine what a films
can be like from a script
all the good things going to be done and
changed and adapted
and also that certain authors
have wonderful predicaments and one of
the things that makes
jane austen so great to adapt normally
is she has great predicaments i mean
they're they're always so interesting
and and sort of subtle
in any case um uh
what happened next was um i did that
film
the last days of disco it wasn't
profitable so
so hollywood wasn't calling immediately
um it was well received but not
profitable
and um i also felt that the three
um dramatic stories i had to tell i kind
of done i had to
have a dramatic experience before i
could do something else
and so i was thinking of doing uh
adaptations i got involved with other
people and
and they all kind of went wrong and
they're all these books under copyright
with living authors and studios and
producers and like
you get four people five people involved
in it everyone likes something different
in the novel everything has everyone has
a different idea
or the memoir or whatever you're
adapting and then
there's a lot of money for each year of
the option you haven't finished the
script it's not good enough and they
don't want to pay for the next year the
option they don't want to buy it out
outright there are all these problems
and living authors are big problems let
me tell you
because living authors very often want
to get into the sausage factory just
when they shouldn't because things are
pretty ugly in the sausage factory
and so they sneakily get like bad early
drafts and read them so this is terrible
and then and then they really do
everything possible to torpedo the
project so
jane austen also has the great virtue
of never wanting to read your script
of never getting involved in any way and
if you can keep it secret um you have to
pay you know it's a public domain
so that's a good thing so i was reading
um jane austen again it's because
i stupidly read north and gravie first
when i was a sophomore in college and
hated it and tell everyone i hate jane
olson she's overrated
she's terrible how can people like her
how can they like her
and then my smart elder sister convinced
me to read something else i read
sentences in civilian loved it and read
everything else and loved it when i was
writing metropolitan
just sort of um paused from the
the the sausage factory of trying to
write the script i'd actually just read
pages of pride and purchase
to clear the palette or cleanse the
brain or whatever so it's reading this
omnibus jane austen
and i ran into all these strange things
all these strange little
things i'd know about so i got a big big
jane austen idea
and then a trivial pathetic sad
ridiculous jane austen idea and the big
big cool jane austen idea
um i immediately got a producer wanted
to do it i took it to
one of the big commercial studios in
england that does all
big romantic you know bridget jones
notting hill all these big things
and i went to them they said we don't
like to do anything
but the biggest novel of an author we
only do the biggest novel
guess what novel they did anyway um and
they did they did two of those
both anyway um
so i had this very slight idea this
strange manuscript jane austen left
untitled about will
liddy susan uh decorating her quest for
a wealthy husband for herself and her
daughter
um it was in the epistolary style it was
really hard to read through
there's like a perfunctory wrapping up
at the end not a real
uh conclusion but um what gave me hope
was that i knew
two british actresses who were beautiful
and brilliant at comedy
elizabeth hurley who through hugh grant
was sort of part of the castle rock
group and i knew she's a really smart
producer and really clever
and so elizabeth hurley was the right
age then uh for the part
and um also she's the top of her austin
powers popularity
um there's one time there's there's one
point in time
when elizabeth hurley was the favorite
actress of fourteen-year-old boys
which means a lot in the film business
and um
and kate beckinsale uh kickbex i knew
would be great as lady susan but she was
too young
then because this was like 10 years
before i got the script ready
um and she from last day's disco she
went on to make
to become a gothic action film star
and um anyway but but the idea that an
actress can do it
makes a pro thing more interesting so
i'm curiously i was in london and
happened to have cocktails with a group
of young people
and a writer for city journal and her
boyfriend
was a really nice theatrical
producer very small scale running a tiny
theater in london
he was sort of a scottish awkward nicer
version of hugh grant
um and um he he
i told him this idea uh this strange
idea of lady susan
and he said he'd read it and he read and
he thought you know this could be
interesting sorry
i said why not do it as a little play to
test it out try out the material
and then we could make it maybe into
make it definitely into a movie later
that would be the plan
and so he gave me like a tiny amount of
money that i could well
afford to pay back a very loose contract
and i started working on it
and adapting this with the letters you
sort of
take the letters from alicia to lady
susan
and put several letters together and try
to make it a scene a conversational
scene you've got these essentially
monologue and monologue and monologue
and monologue and monologue and
and you tried to get it to work and then
you had the decorsis
trying to deal with this shark coming
into their world and their letters to
each other
and you start getting something and what
was strange is that
normally a script before you finished it
even when you finished it
it's just terrible for people to read
like normal people cannot enjoy a film
script
it's broken up an interior exterior
night day all the nonsense
and in this case it was really strange
because i was really far away from
finishing the script
but it's really fun to read because a
lot of the stuff i had to do is cut out
funny jane austen stuff but it was there
and so my daughter could read it and
like it and other friends could like it
and i tweeted that i was thinking of
doing a novel
and someone actually actually tweeted
back saying they'd like to see it a
publisher
and i sent them this script i had i
hadn't finished
and they loved it and said oh we'll do a
novel and um
and so i had a contract to do the
derivative knock-off novel before i
had any backing for the film or a
finished script um
and trevor the the play producer he
would always be saying but what about
federica
what about frederica because there
wasn't much about frederick in the
letters and he thought that frederica
had to be the heart
of the film it had to be the heart and
soul and i couldn't think of anything
for federica really
what about frederica anyway in the novel
if you ever read it
there's a lot what about frederica and
we have a lot more about frederick in
the novel anyway
so um trevor went on to do
natural resources investing and
i decided that i hated the theater play
format because
cinema is so brilliant and i hate when
people talk about a great
10 minute shot because the great thing
in cinema is to be able to jump from one
place to another
to cut to get closer to get farther away
to do all these things they're so
wonderful in cinema
and theater doesn't have that now i do
want to do plays
and things like that someday but in this
case it was very frustrating
the idea of adapting it for a play to
later do a movie no why not do the movie
directly so i started doing the movie
script directly
um anyway
there was one key
letter and it was um it was catherine
vernon and
uh like austin scholars write about this
letter
because they say this is the letter
where she's fighting the epistolary
style she's trying to write
modern novel scenes so it's a very long
letter
and in it catherine vernon describes
this silly city man sir james martin
coming to and lady susan's manipulating
him to marry federica and federico
doesn't want to
and he just laughs last laughs and it
was all about how silly he was
but there's actually no matter there's
actually no scene
and so it was very hard to try to come
up with something and i
came up with something and it was pretty
lame and in auditions
i just got so sick of this lame scene i
wrote another scene and
it's a little better but it's still
pretty lame you know
church and hill churchill and all you
know lame
lame stuff then a guy comes in to
audition for it
actually three guys who came in to
audition for it and they were all pretty
good one guy was kind of a genius
and he was so funny with this lame scene
i couldn't believe it
and um we finally got the oh there's
another thing that happened
um that'll interest the investors
upstairs and
in the in the restaurant um a christian
investor
warranted back my jamaican church film
but i wasn't ready to do that i was
trying to do this jane austen film
but he had a son working for him who
said that my script didn't have
christian mission
and um so i think okay what can i do
how do i get the christianity in so i
thought commandments
honor their father and mother
[Applause]
honor thy father and mother is my
favorite commandment
because i'm a father and i i used to
have one
um i i think sort of all
philosophy can come out of that which i
mistakenly
thought was the fourth commandment
anyway meanwhile the other important
commandment is the ninth commander which
we really need these days
um and so i was putting a lot of this
and now i had frederica since because
they could talk about the commandments
and
and frederick was coming into it and
then i said well
i've always wanted to do a sermon i want
to do a sermon on aesthetics so we'll
have a church and accurate
and frederick can go to pray in the
church and the cure can come and give
his little sermon
and and talk about the fourth and fifth
commandments and so suddenly all this
new material was coming in and and this
this
um this story that was just sort of
locked
into this [ __ ] dialogues between
um the two the two characters um
suddenly it started broadening and beer
and then a real eureka moment
was in the um
[Music]
terrible read-through so before you
shoot a film you do a read-through of
all the
actors you have on set we're going
through it's just just
painful the material doesn't sound great
and we just had this
laptop just sitting there and
at one point the laptop started acting
um
and it was sir james martin and he was
incredibly funny and he was
he was skyping in from brighton england
we were in dublin and he was hilarious
and suddenly this disastrous
read-through didn't seem bad and i
started thinking i've got to write a lot
more material for this guy
and um also i mean chloe 7e had come
with a beautiful english accent she'd
worked hard on it's beautiful
but i've been through three films where
there are accent problems where you
worry about the accident
no matter how good it is there's someone
who will say
you know they'll know the actors not
from that place and they'll say that so
we went through this with
a fake accent in in damsels in distress
a woman consciously had a fake accent
and still people would see the trailer
would say oh it's a fake hooks on this
film yeah there is a fake accent it's
intentional
um so i just hated that action and the
assistant director who is english he
took me aside for a pint of
stout guinness in in in dublin as a is
the best
best pint i've ever had because he said
why not make
elisha american and i was in the midst
of just reading about the war of
independence
and the poor tories who went in exile to
nova scotia and back to london and
with their these american families that
atlantis they were just so english they
went to eaton and they read law at the
ends of court and
they were just so english and they came
to the united states and they were
thrown out as they should have been
and they they they went back to to
london and struggled there's some
beautiful artists benjamin west did a
beautiful
a beautiful painting of of of britannia
welcoming
the loyalists back and i i
it's just a it's a striking uh
um striking painting the ingrate traitor
um and anyway so i had all this mature i
knew from my film
i'm about to end i better end um i knew
from my film um
barcelona that people both in the united
states
and europe love characters
snobbing americans everyone thinks
that's funny
and so having all these english people
making comments about her being american
i knew that this is comic gold and
instead of being exiled
so in the jane austen she's the threat
mr johnson gives is to be exiled
to an english village in this case
she'll be
exiled to connecticut to hartford
connecticut
and i knew is going to be a big laugh
line
and anyway um i better wind down i guess
i could keep talking but um i think they
want anyway thank you
thank you
[Applause]
um so if you have a question please come
to a microphone
hello first off i just want to say i
really love your work it's such an honor
to hear you talk
thank you so much one of the things you
mentioned
is how most modern jane austen
adaptations focus on the romance
and one of the reasons i think love and
friendship i like it so much
is that it's very much a comedy of
manners is that part of the reason you
were drawn to it do you think and would
you consider
ever doing another jane austen
adaptation thanks
very much for that uh there were a lot
of things that were really exciting
about realizing how good it was um
so i'd always had real reluctance of
taking one of the great ones and
chopping it down to a classic comic book
movie
um well i know people have done
beautiful jobs with them and a beautiful
job can be done
but they're just so many aspects of the
lady susan material it seemed so
unlikely originally
it's really her funniest material it's
really funny
that humor is kind of buried in this
awkward format i love the fact that
there's no real title to it
and i thought i should take another
austinian title
and used that and that's probably a
mistake um so i took
love and friendship from her earlier
juvenile and put it on this but i felt
it's authentic jane austen title
it didn't have a jane nelson title and i
felt there's a lot of things we could do
there's a lot that had to be added it
was not subtraction it was addition
and to conclude the thing with sir james
martin
so we had the conversations between um
lady susan and her daughter about the
commandments
and in the production van one afternoon
the charming irish producer katie holly
happened to mention the 12 commandments
and i said
katie you made the film
sir james martin the 12 commandments and
then the thing when i was
thinking about that the idea that
um someone corrects and says only 10
said there they're two you get to take
off that was my favorite part
and so uh
i got in the habit i did something with
uh
a pilot with amazon called the
cosmopolitans and they kept asking me to
like write new
scenes so chloe is here couldn't you
have another scene with chloe
and so i'd write a new scene like four
o'clock in the morning and so i realized
you can write new scenes so i kept
writing new scenes uh
so he wrote that like at 4am he got it
in the makeup chair
um and he kept telling the makeup people
take a long time take a long time and it
was just amazing he could do that scene
because he had so little time with the
script and he just took his time
and did it and whenever he come to set i
try to think of a new scene for
him
hello i just wanted to ask how important
you think it is
to be faithful to a novel in a film
adaptation
can i hear that again i just wanted to
ask how important you think it is to be
faithful to a novel in a film adaptation
i mean
i i agree with all sides is that
courageous stance
um so i think it's really electrifying
the
university of soil children's version
you are nothing to it
i mean the important thing it's is that
it's a good film
um and
i had a kind of an argument with a
um a film critic he was a really good
critic who's working for a newspaper
and he was about to see a film and was
rushing to
to read the novel and i said to him oh
please don't do that
that's just the worst thing to do to a
movie to read the novel right before you
see it
and and so i said and i said why do you
do that
it's like this homework to be a good
student they have to do that research
and he said the editors tell us that we
have to do that we have to know the
novel
so we can tell readers if it's faithful
or not
so a lot of readers and newspapers
who've read the no the books
want to know if the if the adaptation is
faithful so it's kind of a market thing
i guess
partly and i said why not read it after
i guess they have deadlines and they
don't have time but when i read it
after you see the movie let the movie
that you're reviewing
be the prime thing and
and then read the um book after it so
um i think with jane austen it's
dangerous changing
too too much but it's it's what people
say i mean you can be faithful to the
spirit
totally in in luck one of the really
outrageous
adaptations i've seen is the
film version of
the evelyn waugh
um the the the sentimental evil in wall
um bride said yeah so
it was a beautiful absolutely beautiful
mini series uh and with jeremy irons
and they redid it as a film i don't know
why
and they completely reversed everything
about it and why do that
i mean it's it's it's
imposing you know whatever your own
little
angle is onto material do different
material
don't do something that you're going to
introduce so thank you for that question
it's great
speakers left thank you sir
so much for your talk um my question is
you talked a lot about how we have
so much material with jane austen and we
have so many adaptations of it and we
might grow tired of it
and then a few years ago there was an
adaptation of pride and prejudice that
took liberties by adding
zombies into the mix and so my question
is do you think that is an indication
of the fact that we're tired of jane
austen and we need
things to make it more entertaining or
is it an example of something that
people
are being super creative with jane
austen's material
um i know that i know the director of
that film
in fact he was an actor in
the third film we did the last days of
disco
he played the door nazi not letting
people in the disco
it's a great guy he and he said he want
to take the part so he could study indie
film and he's done really really well
um maybe that isn't the best one of
uh and he cast three of our actresses in
it it was a little frustrating because
morphed clark was a brilliant
actress who's the first person cast in
the film who plays frederica
and it's going on two big things she's
going on to the big tolkien tv series
and things
she's already done tremendous work um
and
so we cast her for her first film offer
but we weren't ready to film because we
were still looking we hadn't found the
hill sale investors
um everyone made tons of money i have to
say
um and sorry um and
um and so she was in that film before
our film
uh and she's just doing tons of stuff
was that was that the question man
i've had a lot more i could say
so you mentioned film i mean obviously
film adaptations what this talk was
about but um
sense and sensibility specifically i
believe was what you said was
your favorite or the one you respected
the most and
i was just curious as to why you
consider that the best austin
adaptation um i mean i haven't seen
every austin adaptation because some i
just can't bear to
watch them but maybe they get really
good after the first three minutes
um but um
uh i think
that they're aided there by the fact
that it's the lesser of the five
great novels and that
it was a great novel for me to read
first because i was sort of coming from
the world of non-fiction of reading
literary criticism and not the novels
and it's the most esse most like an
essay
and i think that that allowed them to
sort of
take that and um i mean there's so many
beautiful elements in the in that film i
i'm not really a critic so i can't
really say but i don't know i think
i think it's generally i think that's
the general view i think it's generally
the best regarded uh
adaptation and to get back to
pride and prejudice and zombies if i
didn't finish that
um i think it'd be great if they're sort
of a fallow period
and like not so much of the jane austen
or richardson's or whatever it is
and that we just allowed to come back in
a decade or five years and and try to do
really great versions of all the others
that haven't been done as great versions
and i think it really would be great to
think about someone like trollope
and how a feature film could be made of
trout novels
um because a lot of the same dynamic
that people appreciate
there's a lot of morality really kind of
exquisite morality and
humor and trollop it's not works of art
at the same level of jane austen but
there's no need to compare and say one's
better than another and all that it's
just
i'm just so excited to find all these
great troll
novels that i'm reading
uh you briefly mentioned the
cosmopolitans is there an update on that
well i think it might be going in sort
of two directions
i hope to take some elements of it and
put it into different kind of series
so i think things will come out of
cosmopolitans
but it probably won't be you know
directly continuing exactly that
and if anyone needs a link i can get
links to people
thank you so much for your excellent
film and your explanation of it to us
tonight i'm curious
especially after her poignant portrayal
in your film
could you perhaps offer a summary of
your vindication
for lady susan well
um funny you ask
how many minutes do i have okay
i'll quickly read this okay this is the
opening so
this novel so sir james martin
tom bennett that comic performance
really inspired me and also
a very kind of comical
memoir of jane austen by her nephew
so i thought what if lady susan and sir
james martin had a nephew
who wanted to do a defense of his aunt
the way
her nephew did a defense of his aunt
so anyway this fellow turns everything
around
let me just read as much as this as i
can it's the opening of uh
love and friendship um jane austen's
lady susan
vernon entirely vindicated that's that's
the novel because
by the time i've done a film i don't
want the novel to be the film i want the
novel to be something else again
and so this is sort of anyway a true
narrative of false witness they who bear
false witness against the innocent and
blameless are rightly condemned
what though of they who bear false
witness against those whose histories
are not spotless
to commit one sin sinner indiscretion is
not to commit every sin or indiscretion
yet many speak as if it were such is the
case of the decoursy family of
parkland's kent who disguised their
prideful arrogance
indefensible in our faith under the
cloak of moral nicety and correction
as so often with our aristocracy the
decorsis did not conduct their soiling
vendettas themselves
but through the psycho fence and hangars
on in their circle in this case the
spinster arthur s
notorious for her poison pan fictions
hidden under the lambskin of anonymity
that other less prominent character
assassinations later joined the cruel
frey does not lessen that lady's
singular culpability
having myself been the target of such
slanderers i well know the near
impossibility of cleansing one's good
name from their aspersions
and if one's name is not so good that
near impossibility becomes even nearer
whatever one answers no matter how true
and well evidenced the defense or
explanation
one is forever besmirched even
irrefutable denials
this applies to a lot of my friends
who've been in the film business
and and got you know called out for
various things anyway
serve only to further circulate the
original slanders
if defending one's reputation is
difficult while one is still
of this world surrounded by one's papers
correspondence calendars diaries and
overpredictor of every every kind
with memories still lively to marshall
in one's own defense
how much harder after one has departed
it
ladies susan grave vernon was my aunt
and the kindest most delightful woman
anyone could know
a shining ornament to our society and
nation
i am convinced that the insinuations and
accusations made against her
are nearly entirely false i have taken
as my sacred obligation to
task of convincing the world of this
also sir arthur helps the great
biographer of prince henry the navigator
heroic initiator of the age of discovery
has described that prince's not
uncommon motive a man sees something
that ought to be done
knows of no one that will do it but
himself and so is driven to the
enterprise
anyway i think that someone saw our time
thank you thank you may you may you all
be driven to the right enterprises
thank you mr stillman thank you
you